Factory
the atrocities committed by Russian
troops in butcher Urban and elsewhere in
Ukraine have horrified the world
civilians massacred shot dead with their
hands tied
women raped in front of their young
children
bodies crudely burned dumped in Mass
Graves or just left lying in the street
the reports are so shocking and so
sickening it's no wonder your government
is seeking to hide them from you
your president knows that if you could
see what was happening you would not
support his War
he knows that these crimes betray the
trust of every Russian mother who
proudly waves goodbye to her son as he
heads off to join the military
and he knows that they're a stain on the
honor of Russia itself
a stain that will only grow larger and
more indelible every day as this war
continues
but don't just take my word for it
all you need is a VPN connection to
access independent information from
anywhere in the world
and when you find the truth share it
those responsible will be held to
account
and history will remember who looked the
other way
Vash president is
sky is Chief political correspondent
John Craig is in Westminster so it's
interesting isn't it clearly trying to
get around these restrictions on on what
the Russian people are being told
yes the uh the bit of Russian right at
the end meant your president stands
accused of committing war crimes but I
cannot believe he's acting in your name
and the bit at the beginning was um uh
the Russian people deserve the truth you
deserve the truth
um some may find this actor a bit
provocative especially that line just
before the bit of Russian at the end
history will remember who looked the
other way and this follows the prime
minister at pmqs uh last week talking
about no backsliding on sanctions
um clearly irritation from the Prime
Minister and indeed the British
government about some of the European
countries and their reluctance to get
really tough uh with the Russians on
sanctions but uh this is obviously a
move to try and influence public opinion
in Russia and uh some will be impressed
by his command of the Russian language
but this is a first really what we don't
know this stage is whether this is
something president yelenski's asked him
to do or whether it's the prime
minister's own idea but it's certainly
eye-catching and be interesting to see
what reaction it provokes from the
Russians who've already singled out
Boris Johnson as uh they're one of their
leading opponents during this war and I
think we can probably call it a
propaganda War as well